er und hier sind feuerwehr
jede war ich darauf vorbereitet nein das
war ich nicht
das ganze land explodierte
[Musik]
ich hab noch nie vorher gesehen dass
sich gegen den wind ausbreitet
[Musik]
australien ist feuer gewöhnt hat war
nicht in diesem ausmaß dieses ausmaß war
noch nie da das land war außergewöhnlich
trocken
ich glaube nicht dass ich gegen den wie
unsere schule so trocken gesehen man
bringt diese drei sachen zusammen
brennstoff wind und hitze
mehr braucht man nicht um feuer zu
machen und von allen hatten wir
reichlich das ganze land explodierte am
26 november als das feuer bei uns
ausbrach hatten wir windstärken bis zu
100 km/h die dinge dann runter auf 60 es
war extrem windig mit nimmt der wind hat
sich gedreht
er kommt jetzt nicht mehr von norden
sondern von westen ein bisschen
südwesten
er drückt das feuer jetzt man muss sich
entscheiden was die wertvollsten dinge
für einen sind welche sachen wollen wir
nicht verlieren
wie packt man ihn sein auto unterliegen
sie und das gehirn ist die ganze zeit in
hohe alarmbereitschaft war jeden moment
eine sms oder ein anruf kommen kann oder
die feuerwehr fährt die straße runter
und sagt dass man jetzt fliehen oder
sein hab und gut verteidigen muss
als wir in sydney ankamen war der himmel
ein dreckiges orange grau und man konnte
den rauch in der luft riecht und eine
andere sache die ungewöhnlich war
das war unsere sommerurlaub und der
strand der waren verbrannte blätter
einfach überall
beim zweiten feuer wussten wir dass es
kaum
das zweite war ein silvester wir waren
informiert dass es ziemlich schön werden
wird die polizei hat schon tage vorher
an unsere türen geklopft und uns gesagt
ihr müsst gehen wenn ihr weg wollt müsst
ihr jetzt los wenn er jetzt bleibt
bleibt dir denn sie wollten keine leute
auf den straßen
man schläft nicht weil die ganze nacht
feuerwehrautos die straße rauf und
runter fahren mit ihren kleinen lichtern
an silvester sind wir ganz normal zum
strand gegangen aber es war seltsam
es wurde sehr sehr heiß und der wind
wurde immer stärker
es war wirklich unangenehm am strand das
war überhaupt nicht normal
also gingen wir zu unserem ferienhaus
zurück und der strom fiel aus
also wenn etwas passiert laufen wir ja
unser notfallplan ist es direkt zum
strand zu laufen und silvester du hast
keine ahnung was hier passiert oder sie
fliegen genau hierhin schaut euch das an
oh mein gott das ist wirklich nahe
jetzt sind die schuhe an ok her und hier
sind feuer
ich hab noch nie vorgesehen dass sich
gegen den wind ausbreitet der wind geht
in diese richtung
der rauch geht in die richtung um dieses
feuer schaut euch das an
wir stecken tief im dreck
man kann überhaupt nicht sehen
bekommt zweifel
man weiß dass man jetzt mittendrin ist
und man fragt sich ob es die richtige
entscheidung war zu bleiben
es ist knallrot
als der rauch vor meinem haus aufzug
dauerte es noch 15 oder 20 minuten bis
es völlig dunkel wurde
es ist wie mit
man konnte explosion hören
viele leute wissen nicht dass wir hier
bestimmte arten von bäumen haben wir
haben eukalyptusbäume die eine menge öl
in sich haben wenn sie heiß werden sind
sie wie eine bombe und gehen in flammen
auf
das sind vermutlich die schlimmsten
bäume die man bei einem feuer haben kann
schaut euch das an
das ist meine straße zieht euch das mal
rein
ich brauche einen generator für die
wasserpumpen um das haus zu retten
ich hatte kein internet als das feuer
nachmittags kam man hat mit niemandem
kontakt das war's du bist allein
wir hatten großes glück weil der wind im
letzten moment drehte und es viel kühler
wurde
wir packten unsere sachen und hatten
zwei rucksäcke mit den wichtigsten dinge
ich hatte die trage für unseren
zweijährigen und direkt zum strand
laufen zu können ich weiß wir müssen
hier blieb die ganze nacht wach und ich
habe versucht mit unserem sohn ins bett
zu gehen und zu schlafen aber ich bin
alle 30 minuten aufgewacht um zu gucken
ob alles okay ist die luft war voller
rauch sogar im haus
man wacht aufregendes beißenden rauch
es regnet
bitte hör nicht auf zu regnen am zweiten
abend kam ganz spät das internet so mama
und date haben es geschafft mit einer
polizei-eskorte her zu kommen weil wir
hier festsitzen
jule ist schon im auto wir versuchen
jetzt raus zu kommen
es gibt lange staus weil alle versuchen
wegzukommen wir werden also lange im
auto sein
aber hier muss in der nähe ein feuer
sein weil die flugzeuge ganz tief in
diese richtung fliegen
es ist das beste abzuhauen und dann
steckten alle für vier stunden auf der
straße fest wann ein neues feuer
angefangen hatte während sie versuchten
die leute zu evakuieren mussten sie also
die straße sperren weil ein weiteres
feuer aufgaben das ist das was leute
meinen wenn sie sagen diese feuer sind
unberechenbar
das dritte feuer war anlass das kann
wirklich nahe
wir hatten einen helikopter der direkt
hinter meinem haus wasser aus dem see
aufnahm
ich konnte das gesicht des piloten sehen
er schaute mich an ich schaute ihn an
und machte fotos
er hat zweieinhalb minuten gebraucht um
das wasser aufzunehmen als abzuwerfen
und wieder zurück zu kommen
das macht er zwei stunden lang wenn
dieser helikopter nicht gewesen wäre
wären alle häuser hier verbrannt es ist
als hätte man ein monster vor der tür
wenn diese feuer eine bestimmte größe
erreichen werden sie fast wie ein liebe
genießen
viele feuerwehrleute die seit jahren
gegen feuer kämpfen seien das gleiche
die feuer sind wie tiere
sie wollen gegen dich kämpfen denn new
south wales wurden bewohner und
touristen auf grund einer verschärfung
der lage aufgefordert zu fliehen
die warnung kommt inmitten einer
zunehmenden krise in der benzin
nahrungsmittel und wasservorräte
gefährlich genutzt werden ich weiß nicht
was hier passieren wird ich habe eine
menge essen und eine menge wasser
das problem ist dass benzin geht mir ich
hätte 80 liter benzin haben sollen ich
wusste nicht dass sich drei wochen lang
keinen strom haben werde
wir hatten keinen strom kein internet
kein telefonnetz und wir hatten kein
auto
ich hatte glück dass ich noch kaufen
konnte ich konnte noch esse ich musste
nicht in die evakuierung center gehen zu
denen essen geliefert wurde
die armee hat essen gebracht manchmal
kam lkws durch die leute hatten keine
vorräte darauf bist du nicht vorbereitet
es war wie im krieg unser essen wurde
sehr knapp ich glaube wir hatten noch
eine packung chips
und ein paar müsliriegel das war alles
was wir haben fast zwei lkw-ladungen nur
brot brot muss man nicht kaufen man kann
ein sandwich machen man braucht keinen
strom
es ist für die leute praktisch wenn die
bedrohung nachlässt wenn das feuer
vorbei ist und sich alles etwas beruhigt
scheint man zu fallen
die energie ist weg nun ist ausgelaugt
und mental bricht man zusammen der sind
so lange durch diese gegend gefahren
alles war komplett ausgebrannt
wenn man daran denkt wie viel natur
zerstört wurde
es war wirklich traurig ich habe ein
kurzes video für unseren youtube-kanal
gemacht und traurige musik darunter
gelegt
[Musik]
wo ich lebe schaue ich auf wasser und
auf die natur
es ist ein sehr schöner ort aber zu
sehen wie es über zwei monate immer und
immer wieder brannte und alles wurde rot
braun schwarz
man fühlt sich wie auf einem anderen
planeten
es ist das wäre mal nicht mehr zu hause
ich habe gelesen dass der bus 100 jahre
braucht um sich zu erholen
buschfeuer sind ein natürlicher teil von
australien
einige pflanzen brauchen die feuer um zb
aus zu können
aber diese feuer waren so viel stärker
und so anders als bisherige feuer
es ist schlimmer als alles an dass wir
uns in diesem land erinnern können viele
leute sagen nein das war nur ein
weiteres feuer und das war's aber das
weiß nicht es war keine normale feuer
saison als jemals zuvor getroffen die
weihnachtszeit vom 25 dezember bis zum
ersten januar eingeladen machen da ihr
ganzes geld den rest des jahres können
sie gerade mal ihre miete bezahlen
das ist dieses jahr nicht passiert wie
viele von diesen kleinen geschäften
werden aufgeben müssen
einige leute werden ihre häuser
verlieren obwohl sie nicht abgebrannt
sind aber sie können dafür nicht mehr
zahlen weil sie der bank geld schulden
versicherungen denken ernsthaft darüber
nach in bestimmten gegenden überhaupt
nicht mehr zu versichern weil das risiko
zu hoch ist
ich glaube dass zukünftig viele menschen
kein grundeigentum mehr besitzen werden
weil sie es nicht wieder aufbauen können
oder weil sie das risiko nicht mehr
eingehen wollen die lokale polizei und
feuerwehr haben fantastische arbeit
geleistet
aber natürlich haben sich die leute
gefragt warum die armee nicht früher
gerufen wurde
warum gab es keine pläne oder
ausreichende vorkehrungen mehrere
feuerwehr chefs wollten sich mit dem
premierminister schon vor monaten
treffen sie sagten dass so etwas
passieren wird
sie wollten ihn treffen aber er hat sich
geweigert ein wichtiger punkt ist dass
die feuerwehr in den ländlichen gebieten
nur aus freiwilligen besteht
das sind die leute die in diesem
riesigen wälder gehen um gegen diese
schweren feuer zu kämpfen und sie haben
nur zwei ganz normale feuerwehrautos ich
habe geweint weil es einfach so
verzweifelt wirkte und das passierte
überall in australien
der klimawandel sorgt für die passenden
umstände bei diesen dingen und dafür
dass die feuer stärker sind und früher
auftreten als sonst
dafür dass sie länger dauern für mich
ist das die realität des klimawandels
wir erwarten einfach dass die regierung
etwas dagegen unternimmt
wir erwarten dass international etwas
dagegen unternommen wird aber das
passiert nicht
ich glaube wir müssen politisch aktiver
sein wir müssen protestieren und wir
müssen zeigen dass wir eine starke
stimme es gibt aber habe ich angst dass
das feuer in zehn jahren zurück und wenn
sich nichts ändert
oh ja es wird gerade darüber diskutiert
ob in einigen gegenden schon wieder
buschfeuer alarm ausgerufen werden soll
denn obwohl so viel verbrannt ist kommt
die hitze zurück das muss sich ein land
[Musik]